(rap music)
- Good morning, Good morning,
Good morning Vayner Nation
it is July 1st.
A beautiful day, hope
everybody has the best
best July of their entire life.
It's been a very intriguing 2020
but yesterday brought me so much hope.
What an incredible episode
of Tea with GaryVee,
big shout out to Alexis and to Dustin.
Dustin, the post we put up on Instagram.
If everybody's watching,
that full Alexis interview
is on Instagram right now.
I just posted a new announcement,
literally just posted
while we were doing the preview,
my latest post on Instagram.
A little bit of a fun announcement
but the prior post is the
entire interview with Alexis
but it ends with something
pretty interesting,
which is, Dustin, yesterday, we ended
with an emotional moment with me and you
about saying you're sorry,
taking accountability.
And you went out and did it?
- Yeah.
- So thanks for everybody who's
continuing the show process.
- So right after, like I did,
I felt like I needed
to, right after the show
So I just did that.
- Using momentum, using momentum?
- Yeah.
And reached out,
didn't hear from any of them initially,
for like an hour,
and then got back and my one friend said,
thanks for reaching out
and like his family's
doing all good and stuff,
and I just apologized again.
He said, it's not even a big
deal, so don't worry about it.
And the other one pretty much said.
He, like took some blame too
- Yeah I saw that
- So I thought that was awesome
because I didn't think he would,
like he just looked for the
last conversation we had.
It didn't seem like that.
- And when was the last conversation?
- Maybe like three years ago.
- A lot changes in three years, brother.
- Yeah.
- A lot of growth.
And then the one didn't respond,
but then he got to me later
- Oh he did?
- Yeah.
- So did he too?
- Yeah, he just said,
thanks for reaching out.
It's all good.
And the one that I brought up yesterday,
the one that it did like last week,
he got back to me too.
And he said, it's all good too.
So it just shows how like I don't know,
- Do you like legitimately
feel different today?
- Yeah, like, a weight is
completely off my chest.
Just feels a lot more because I guess that
like the biggest reason is because,
I just had a lot of anxiety,
like, going to events
where I might run into them
and just been like awkwardness
of not knowing what to do.
- I basically lived my life
because I don't want to run
into somebody and have a
negative vibe in the air.
It just doesn't have any value.
- Yeah.
- Yes, it was incredible.
Thank you, Dustin.
Yesterday was incredible.
If you didn't watch the
episode, it is on YouTube.
If you didn't see the Alexis
interview that led to Dustin,
last couple of minutes,
it is my second to last
post right now on Instagram.
And, and let's continue with the show.
Sara.
- Hello.
- Hello
- Wow (laughs)
I've been trying to ask
this question with you
for about two years,
and I've been following you
for just the longest time
and I just wanna say that I know
legacy is really important to you,
and I don't think that you
could ever really understand
like down in the weeds what
it does for people day to day.
It's like I'm 56 I mean
that kid, you know,
he's a little boy.
And he's all worried about everything.
I'm 56 I shouldn't be
asking anyone for permission
to do things, but when I do, it's you,
I come to you and you give me
the permission to do stuff.
- Thank you Sara.
Where do you live?
You're very sweet.
- Wyoming Montana, out
in the middle of nowhere.
- I love it.
I can't believe that literally
my dad brought up Montana just last week.
Being intrigued and
maybe wanting to go there
and just live in the middle of nowhere.
So, I mean not really but he was intrigued
we literally were talking about
Montana for like 25 minutes.
He was asking me about it
like do I know it and things
and it was really funny conversation.
He just loves the outdoors
and the old country
and things of that nature.
So anyway, nonetheless, yes, Sarah,
what can I help you with?
- If he wants to come out here,
what I do is Native American tourism.
Send him my way I'll take
him all over the place.
- I will take him out.
- I will let you know.
Thank you.
Dustin, save Sara's info.
All right, Sarah.
- Okay, so what I do, it's
Native American tourism.
And it's a tiny niche, and it's like,
cultural tourism is like a
82 billion dollar industry.
And I think it's $700
billion in tourism generally,
that's how much you
know Americans spend on
on going on vacations every year.
But I can't make my business much bigger
without a wider recognition
for Native American tourism,
because it's not a thing you know,
people don't even know it exists.
So part of what I want to do is
I wanna create a brand that
brings everybody together
because Native American tourism,
it's all tiny little
operated here and there,
and everybody's struggling,
everybody's small.
People are working in places
where the internet isn't great
and all that kind of stuff.
So what I wanna do is I
wanna dump my business,
I want to give it to somebody
else, let them run it
and I want to set up something
that's like a Native American Expedia.
And so all the back office stuff.
- Are you prepared to be
in the technology business?
- No--
- Because this is where,
I'm sorry to interrupt.
This is where it's very powerful.
A lot of people in the
last 20 years I've sat with
that see the opportunity
and wanna do the tech thing,
The Expedia, the Google the Facebook have,
and I always ask this
question very aggressively
because it's a very real opportunity.
But if you do not have
a technical co founder,
the ambition is too big.
You can't outsource this,
you can't have somebody build this.
If you're truly talking
about what you just said,
you're now 100% in the
technology business.
There's a lot of people watching right now
who've got an idea for an app.
And they wanna hire and
they go and like find a team
to build it in India or Poland or Belarus
or an American app company.
And then it always fails
because they're not in
the technology business.
Apple makes an update,
there's a change on Google
like the site's broken.
Like, if you're gonna
build a technology company,
and you're not a technologist, a CTO
a Chief Technical
Officer, you need to 100%
have a partner minimumly
a CTO who's got a real percentage
of the business and cares.
Otherwise, it will always,
always, always fail.
So just keep that part in mind.
- I totally will.
I really appreciate you saying that.
And do you think that
I can start it though
using one of the like the systems?
It's already there.
I mean, there's all
kinds of like consistent,
you don't think I should?
- Let me rephrase.
You could, no, actually, that's not fair.
I would say you could
just know that if you're
gonna go there, building on it
you could probably do
that for a year or two,
but like, you're gonna wanna build this,
but technology businesses are super hard.
- Right
- Super hard, which is
great, which is great.
I'll tell you what my
hesitation reservations are.
I want you to have a technical co founder.
- Okay.
- I've seen it 80,000 to one to zero.
You know that people just
get into the tech business
and don't know anything about tech.
- Right
- Or not enough to build
a technology platform.
- Right, I definitely don't
know enough to do that.
- And the good news is, there
are a lot of people that do
that would love to get
maybe very fascinated.
What's nice about a niche is a niche
and here's your Facebook.
And I mean, right now,
there may be a developer
who absolutely is fascinated by your niche
and wants to do this with you,
because he or she wants
20, 15 to 49% of a company
50% of the company,
however you figure it out.
And instead of being a coder
at Conde Nast or the NFL
wants to take that leap with
you, now with remote work,
but just do not go into this venture
if you're gonna do it without
a true partner of some sorts
in building tech.
- Okay, got it.
- Number one mistake people do
when they go into a technology business.
- Okay
- If somebody built an
app cheap, never works.
- Right, Okay, so here's my next question,
which is kind of like
that one of the things
I know about my business
is that the sawdust
that like, the sawdust of the business
is the people who don't travel
because they're really
interested in Native America.
But for whatever reason,
they're not coming out here.
And those are the people
that I've wanted to reach
for a long time.
And like, here we are now.
And like, virtual is all
the travel industry's got.
I mean, my business is leveled.
I'm done for this season for definite.
I don't know what's
gonna happen next season,
which is why I'm thinking I
need to get on with this now.
But because there's all of
those people who don't travel,
and because I've wanted to put
something together for them.
The thing is, I wanna know, aching to know
what your hunches for the travel industry
because I've listened
to you over and over say
You know, don't be the
first in virtual experiences
and virtual travel,
because the big boys need to do that first
and it's so far away that
things have changed now.
- No, everything's different now still.
We've been in COVID for hundreds
of days or 100 days plus
or what have you
Has anybody here heard of somebody sitting
in a virtual glasses for five hours?
It's not a human behavior yet.
- Right
- I agree with you.
If, by the way, if VR
was where social media was in 2006
and this happened, oh my god,
it's why direct to consumer
eCommerce has exploded.
eCommerce was far enough along.
This happens now we're
all buying that way.
VR, if it was lucky enough as a technology
to have been to the point
where every one of us
had a VR unit in our home
But just didn't use it
it would have completely
exploded but there is still no
consumer examples at scale
of people using VR
in a meaningful way
Of course there's cutting
edge technology nerds
and enthusiasts playing here and there
but even they aren't going
at it super hardcore yet.
Virtual travel, you know
go into a room in my house
like a theater or put on a
thing or get the contact lenses
and we're talking decades
away still at this point
from what how I see it.
Now tomorrow somebody
might invent something
just like the iPhone was invented
and I'll be like, nope, changed my mind.
This is not ready.
This is the thing but
right now there's nothing.
- So in terms of a virtual
I mean, then in that case,
I can create tours that
are like part virtual
and I send a box to people
and they open the box
and there's stuff in there
and they could get online.
- Yes, yes
A box with you doing two or three hours
talking about that and being
a subscription, very real.
- Okay
- Very real, if you're
gonna worry about you know,
next year which is worth worrying about,
It's definitely worth standing that up.
- Do you think that's
gonna go on for a while?
What's your hunch on that?
- On COVID?
- Well not COVID itself but I mean, like,
on people's willingness to move
when everybody's found Zoom.
Everybody can do everything at home now.
- I think they will.
I think they'll do more Zoom.
I will, but there's a lot of things
you still need to go for.
If you need to go see
some fucking you know,
Native American ship in
Montana, you need to go see it.
- Yeah
- Like it's still different.
Like looking at a picture of Time Square,
or video of Time Square
is different than being
on a fucking Time Square.
Looking at the Grand Canyon
on TV, so like, yeah, I mean,
people will adapt.
I think a lot of us will interact
with people more on video.
You know,
FaceTime versus phone
calls up, like enormously
all those kind of things.
We've learned some communication things,
but people wanna move around.
The reason we have an issue with COVID
is people wanna move around.
If we were disciplined and just sat,
but people love being
social with each other.
So I'm gonna move, Sarah, love you.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome. Bye.
So sweet, Let's keep it moving.
- Hey
- Hey Shavonne, how are you?
- Good. How are you? Good morning.
- I'm amazing. Good Morning too
- So I'm like, so nervous now (laughs)
- Where are you from?
- I'm from Canada.
It's Canada Day now, so wearing
- I love it.
What part of Canada?
- I'm from Ontario
originally from Mississauga.
But right now I live in the sticks.
Nobody knows what it's called so it's fine
- Good.
Rock and roll, let's move
- Okay, so (exclaims)
brief,
brief background.
- Please
- Two years ago, I was
diagnosed with chronic anxiety.
It does run in the family
but we also have a history of
not being diagnosed in time
for proper care.
There was a whole bunch
like going on with that,
like my grandmother
sick, she's got dementia,
we're extremely close.
So that was devastating to me at the time.
I wasn't happy where I was like work wise
I ended up quitting my job
and going traveling for two years.
So I lived in Australia for
a year and I just came back
because of COVID and gained some clarity
and more, I guess, self confidence.
So basically now what I'm doing is
I've just started
freelancing in marketing.
And then I've also started my
podcast like four weeks ago,
or five weeks ago.
And I was supposed to be launching
a travel concierge service
for traveling to Trinidad for carnival.
I don't know if you know
anything about the--
- I do, I do
- Okay, So I've been a couple times
I absolutely love Trinidad.
It's my favorite country
out of the 14 countries that I've been to.
And I got that idea because
I just had a lot of friends
asking me about Trinidad
and what to do for carnival.
So I did organize one group
for this past carnival.
But because I was in Australia,
I didn't take on anymore.
And so yeah, I was supposed to launch that
full force this year.
Obviously I'm not gonna do that
because they're not even
opening the borders.
But I do still want to
do it for 2022 carnival.
So I would launch next year
because you have to plan
like a year in advance
- I totally understand.
- But I'm kind of struggling
with how to balance
marketing those three things for myself
because I don't wanna have
like three different pages.
- Do them all on one page.
- Yeah, the thing is, like I don't know
like I do freelance
marketing for other people
and it's perfectly fine like
my client that I have now
is a fitness company in Toronto
And you know like that's
great it's been going amazing
like she's giving me referrals
but when it comes to me
I don't really know like how
I should market those three things
obviously the travel
one I have to wait but--
- Are you insecure about the
feedback on an individual basis
or you're concerned
about blending the three?
- I think it's more
about blending the three.
- Why?
- I just I don't know
- You don't think it's right,
somebody told you to focus on one?
let's play we're here to
like fucking tee it up.
- Yeah,
well I don't really know
like how to market myself as
a marketer.
I know that sounds really
controversial like a contradictory
- No, no, no,
Maybe you think it's cheesy?
- I don't, Yeah, I guess
because like I came back with the intent.
- You know what's funny, go ahead
- I came up with in the intent
to work at a marketing agency
to get more experience because I graduated
like two three years ago.
And then obviously I was traveling
so I don't have as much experience
because it's really competitive.
- Yeah, you're worried
about being an imposter.
You're worried about, you know, faking it.
And you might be concerned
of marketing yourself as a marketer
if you don't feel like you're there yet.
- Yeah.
- Do you believe that?
Is that true?
- Kind of I mean,
- If it's not, don't like
you're not making me feel good.
I wanna know the answers.
- I know that I have a ways to go
but I know that I know
what I'm talking about
for the things that I do talk about.
- So what's the problem?
- When it comes to things like for me,
I don't know if it's like
an insecurity thing or
it's an insecurity. (laughs)
- Of course yes.
That's okay, like that's okay.
We can hack it that.
To me, the bigger thing
is, that's why I asked you.
Are you worried about the
feedback in the insecurity
on the individual level
or is it worried about the
you know, about the mixing of the three
and you went with the mixing of the three,
but it's probably just the
insecurity of the overall thing.
- Sure
- No?
- I guess to a degree like I--
- Maybe a mix, maybe like 30%
of one and 40% of the other.
- Yeah, it's a bit of both.
Like, I don't know.
- Listen, here's the biggest thing.
- Yeah
- None of it matters.
- True.
- My favorite thing to do
and I got a lot going on.
And when I'm in my most
like, laying in bed,
like concerned about something
I literally go to a place of like,
nobody gives a fuck about me.
Who gives a fuck?
doesn't matter.
It's actually a weird thing.
It's actually a very, go
ahead pour your water.
I know you need it.
- (laughs) It's my coffee
- Tea, coffee, Shavonne It
sounds like an interesting way
to go about it
but it's like, it's
actually a humility thing,
not an insecurity thing.
You know, the answer is that
it doesn't matter, right?
- Yeah, I guess I have like,
I'm really good at making plans
and strategies and whatnot.
But I guess like the execution part
when it comes to me
- Yes, because you're worried about
what happens after you
execute, everyone's great.
It's why people love to
hide behind perfection.
People are like, you don't
get it I'm a perfectionist.
That's why I don't post,
I'm like you're not a perfectionist.
You're scared.
You like talking big game,
but you don't like for it
to be out there because then
it's actually getting judged.
You're not comfortable with judgment.
Is what I say that, you know,
I'm going kind of macro here
not necessarily what's here.
I think for me,
what I'm trying to figure out
especially when as I throw things out,
You're like, Nah, which is amazing.
What I'm trying to figure out is
how to get you to understand,
that forget about me
forget about you.
Like, the only way it actually
works out is by doing.
Like all the answers that
you're trying to figure out
within your own head in these 13 minutes,
they're all irrelevant at some level
until you start to get
to the process of doing.
Only doing gets you to the answer.
- Yeah, I know that (laughs)
I guess it's more so like,
in addition with this,
the executing of these
plans, I'm very indecisive,
so before I--
- That's the same thing though.
You know that right?
It's all the same, you're indecisive.
You're like it's all the same game.
It's all to not let you
do the fucking thing.
Shavonne literally the
first 25 posts I put out
about business, 85% of the comments
were stay in your lane wine boy
literally me, where I'm at.
Stay in your lane wine boy.
You're selling out Gary, why
you talking about business?
You're a wine guy.
Like don't talk about
shit you don't know, wine
You can't live for feedback.
- Okay
No it makes you, because
I've been listening to you
for a while so I knew this was happening.
- You know that every
characteristic you have
is leading to your fear of the feedback.
It's just a self esteem game.
- Yeah, you're right.
You know, what's amazing,
It's a winnable game.
A lot of people resigned
to the fact that like,
well my grandma was like
this, My mom was like this,
I'm like this, like they
just kind of resigned to it
- With the anxiety you mean?
- Forget about anxiety, you know, yes
I know you brought up that fact
but I'm just talking in the macro.
Like when you sit here and
you're like you're right.
And everyone's sitting and
thinking about themselves
and saying you're right
and I think about the
things that I was scared of
whether it was swimming or riding a bike
or it was fear of those
kind of things, you know it,
but it's back to swimming
and riding a bike
or kissing a boy or girl.
All of It's so scary until you do it.
And then you spend all your
time saying to yourself,
The fuck was I scared of?
- So, like is there--
- That's why you love creating for others
because you're good at it,
but you don't get the feedback.
That company does and
you're behind the scenes.
- (laughs) That's exactly it.
And they usually just
give me the good feedback.
- By the way, by the way,
there's nothing wrong,
being that kind of
operator in business too.
What I don't want is
for you to go that route
and never address what makes
you anxious or concerned
about other people's opinions.
You know, I often talk about
a lot of them about like,
don't take positive feedback too heavy,
because then negative
feedback gets you, right?
and you've been on I'm reading
the comments, you know,
lots of like, "She's so
beautiful, She's so beautiful
She's so beautiful."
One of the one of the things
I talk about a lot is like,
one thing that you may wanna think about,
and this is like the first
time I've, I've said a lot,
but I don't talk about it.
I haven't had the opportunity
to really talk to somebody about it.
One of the things for
you to really think about
is not get too high when
people give you compliments.
- Yeah
- It's really worked for me Shavonne,
It's really worked for me.
Like, it's unbelievable to me
how it goes through my chemicals
when people are like you're
the goat, you're the greatest
you change peoples
lives, you walk on water.
It doesn't get me too
high, it really doesn't.
Which then protects me
when people are like,
You're the worst, you
know, stays in the pocket.
- Okay.
- Of course there's, you know,
that might be something to think about,
that might be something to think about
when somebody comes at you
like, you're so beautiful
you're great at work or you're amazing,
this was the best trip I've ever been on.
You appreciate it, but you
don't think you're somebody
which then ironically helps you
when somebody says you're
shit, ths is the worst Carnival
or I didn't like this video
or that post is stupid
or why are you mixing dumb
shit or your page looks weird
it's not or you know, I don't like the way
your Instagram looks 'cause
it's all over the place.
Like all of a sudden, you
appreciate the feedback.
You understand you listen, you respect it,
but you don't think you suck,
You think one person has an
opinion, then this isn't great.
- Yeah.
What type of content should I put out
for like the freelancing 'cause
I do wanna start taking on
- A video,
a video of you straight to camera saying
hey, I wanna take on more clients.
I'm a freelance marketer.
In this video you'll see
some of the stuff I've done
(mumbles) little editing,
doesn't have to be fancy.
posted on LinkedIn and
Instagram and Facebook.
Ask, ask.
- Okay.
And then should I do that same
thing for like, TikTok too?
- Hell yeah.
- I'm struggling on TikTok. (laughs)
- Listen, you're not struggling on TikTok.
You haven't found it yet
- Yeah, that's true.
I've been trying like
different types of content
to see like--
- How many posts you have on TikTok?
- I don't know, maybe 30, 40
- Just not enough.
- Actually more than that,
does it tell you how many?
if you haven't done a 1,000,
you're not struggling.
- Yeah definitely not a 1,000
- You just haven't found
it yet, you're early.
- True
- You struggle that walk in the first
18 months of your life.
- True.
- Just early girl.
Just fucking early.
- Okay, and what are your, actually no
I don't wanna take any more
time from anybody else.
I'm good, Yeah.
- Are you?
what did you get from this?
- Not to let good or
negative comments get to me.
- Did that one hit you?
Does that make sense to you?
- Yeah it does make sense
- I'm basically trying to figure out
why you're scared to post something.
- I think it's just like
the overall anxiety of it.
- But the anxiety comes, go ahead
- Like before I went traveling,
I wanted to be in the fitness industry.
So like, my whole page was
all fitness and I had classes
I had clients, I thought
I was doing really good.
And then when I was kind of
going through all of that,
like my grandma was diagnosed
and I was diagnosed.
Like, I was just kind of like confused
because I took your advice and I went out
and like I was offering
people free classes
and I messaged like, 100 different,
like fitness influencers on Instagram.
A couple of them responded,
one of them actually,
gave me his numbers so that I could call
and ask him questions about
it, about the industry.
He's like, yeah, like, we
have this group in Toronto.
If you wanna come and like,
learn some tips, feel free.
But like talking to these people,
I've realized like I didn't
have the passion that they had
for fitness
- Good
- I liked fitness, and I liked helping,
I like to help and that was the thing.
I like helping people
no matter what it is.
And so that's why I kind of thought like
- That's amazing.
- Yeah.
And so I guess I went from that
and then had a mental
breakdown and I went traveling
and now people ask me still they're like,
oh, like you don't work out anymore?
I'm like, No, not really.
I just kind of go for walks
- That's good.
Shavonne, that's good.
Shavonne listen to me.
You have to spend every
second of your life,
every second of your life,
not valuing other people's
opinions about your life.
Ready?
We're gonna role play,
you're Johnny Magoo.
I'm gonna be Shavonne.
Like Johnny Magoo, What's up,
Shavonne, you're not working out anymore?
No. Are you?
Like, that's it?
(laughs)
He's like, yeah, but then
he's like, I'm crushing
I'm like, and how's your this?
and how's your relationship with your dad?
Like everybody's got something.
Do not value other people's opinions.
Respect them, understand it, think it,
but it doesn't fucking matter.
When you're 92 you're
not gonna give a fuck
about the random person that
asked you if you worked out
in fucking 2020, promise.
Other people's opinions,
period.
- You right
- I know but start practice.
You know how when you were
working out it was reps,
Every day, every day.
- My aunt's in the background (laughs)
- Hi Auntie
That's it.
Got it?
- Yeah.
- Hit me up if you need me in the future.
Talk soon
- Thank you
- Bye
Look, these things are
not fixed in 17 minutes
with me on a fucking YouTube show.
You know, like, this is real shit
but the themes matter and
they matter to a lot of you
so let's keep it moving.
- Oh my god.
- What's up, how are you?
- What's up Adam and Danny?
- I'm Adam, this is Danny.
- How's it going Gary?
I'm Danny Zabaleta.
I wanna thank you for the opportunity.
This is an honor for me to be here, man.
So the dream of mine.
Before we get started to the question,
I want to share some of the story
of how you've influenced me
and I followed your advice
before I got into this career field.
I love your philosophy about
mindset, self awareness,
and doubling down on your strengths.
That's exactly what I did in
order to get into this field
being brand new, without
having any knowledge.
I met with Adam.
And I said to him, I don't
have any knowledge of the field
but I know I want to get
into something different,
and I want to work for free.
And I entered from, I was
bartender at the time,
and I you know, interned for like,
three months or so working
for free, learning the process
being patient, and I want
to thank you for that.
It helped me a ton, so I
really do appreciate that.
- And let me say something
off of that Danny like
For everybody's who's watching.
Being patient, the process,
three months is nothing.
Shout out to Adam for like that's nothing.
Listen, let me rephrase that.
90 days going hard working
for free is something
it's actually remarkable but like,
fuck if you wanna be happy,
people talking about happiness out here
if you wanna be happy, fucking three years
if you wanna be happy, right?
like so anyway, nonetheless
that's fantastic
that you did that, it's
fantastic on the flip side
that you didn't have to
do it for so long either
- For sure.
- So Danny has been with us for a year.
So Danny and I represent
a Home care agency
here in Naples, Florida.
I don't know if you know
much about Home care,
but typically in simple terms,
we help the aging population
age in place at their homes.
So looking back at what you did in the 90s
of disrupting the wine industry,
how do you disrupt an industry
that's so traditionally
tried and true like Homecare?
- By building reputation on Facebook
because everybody who's 50
to 90 lives on Facebook.
- For sure
- I fucking live on Facebook.
- For sure, for sure.
So, obviously right now, traditionally--
- Real quick, real quick
Hold on one second.
I got a comment here from Sean Thomas.
"I tried to work for free got turned down"
Once Sean, do it another 90 times.
Keep going.
- So obviously Coronavirus
has played a huge impact
in our day to day.
You know, typically on a regular
week we're in the hospitals
rehabs, this is the living
is doing sales calls.
So we have shifted to you
know, really doubling down
on social media, digital
marketing, Facebook being--
- Facebook.
- Facebook, right.
So right now that's why I
want to kind of question is
Facebook's our main platform
and we've dived into LinkedIn,
I think helps--
- Facebook.
How many posts a day and how many?
Yeah, bro straight up.
If I was the third partner,
we would probably post on Facebook
in the 40 mile radius of Naples, Florida
25 times a day while
running 100 different ads
with 30 to $40 per ad against
them, if we can afford it.
- Okay, okay.
- We will start a Facebook group,
let me just say one more time.
30,40,50,60 pieces of content a day.
I go live for an hour a day.
I would ask our favorite
Homecare, you know clients
if they wanna do Facebook with us.
For some of them that's gonna
bring them joy and happiness.
- Right
- For us, that's a testimonial
from a real fucking person.
All of a sudden your tried is true is fuck
when they see Gertrude
saying you're the best.
(laughs)
- I know you've said,
double down on TikTok.
Do you think TikTok is not
appropriate for Homecare?
- Let me tell you why.
If you said to me you were
posting 60 times a day
on Facebook and you had more
bandwidth, then I'd be like,
okay, let's strategize about
the granddaughters becoming,
you're not even a
fucking game on the thing
that you have to do 80%
of your energy against.
When I talk about do everything, you know?
That's right in the macro.
The reason I do Tea with GaryVee is
now I'm hearing your exact business.
And your exact business
needs to fucking go hammy,
ham, hammy ham, ham.
- For sure, for sure.
Now, do you think like
LinkedIn would be a good avenue
for like referral sources?
- I think you're being
theoretical, which is fantastic.
You know, like, you're trying to be
thoughtful and theoretical.
But you're fucking ass
needs to get serious
about Facebook, bro.
- Yeah
- I'm looking for 60
piece of content today.
I'm looking for a fucking
hour on Facebook Live.
I'm looking for you to reach
out to all your clients
and ask them if they want to do Facebook,
like you have work to do.
Don't talk to me about
any other fucking app.
- Yeah, we're doing segments
on Facebook actually,
we're doing like a three a three.
So we're bringing on
like referral partners
and community resources.
So we're doing stuff
not to the volume that
you're probably saying.
So we do have work to do.
- How many pieces of content
do you put out every day
on Facebook organically,
in Facebook group, or running
an ad against it, flat out?
Tell me the truth.
- Maybe two, yeah.
You're 100 years away
from the opportunity.
- Now and when we're
talking about content,
I mean, there's so many
different avenues you can go
like for me, I want people
to understand the purpose.
Like why do I get--
- Good news, ready for this?
ready for this Adam?
when you're doing 60 a day,
everything out of your
little fucking beautiful head
is gonna be able to be done.
I don't give a fuck of everything
that you're about to say,
all of it is gonna be Yes.
Why I get up in the morning,
Gertrude fucking journey,
Things that people aren't thinking about,
why Alexa is good for grandparents.
Like all of it.
That's what's amazing about 60,
I have to debate which fucking post.
- For sure, for sure.
Crazy All right, well, yeah,
just that means investment in time.
Push, push, push.
- Of course the time,
but we're trying to
build a business out here
the fuck are we doing?
- Yeah.
- Listen to me Danny, 60
fucking pieces of content
you know how much work that is?
- It's a lot.
- It's a ton.
You gotta design some pictures,
you gotta go take some photos,
you gotta go interview people,
but I really like using
your current clients
if they're into it, I'll tell you why.
They're gonna like it.
Some are private as fuck.
- Right
- Some are embarrassed that they're 90 now
like there's a million different things.
But there's some people
that, is they're lonely
and doing this content with
you bring you happiness.
- Do you think that's a
big enough differentiator
because there's other home care agencies
which I applause I mean,
listen, I'm not afraid of competition.
But there's a lot of people
are trying to do the same thing
- Doesn't matter what competition,
I'm playing basketball every day,
and I'm not fucking LeBron James.
- Right
- Do you know how many
fucking GaryVee wannabes
there are right now?
(laughs)
- A lot
- And guess what?
Right now there's 13 year old Sarah D
and she's gonna come along and beat my ass
and become number one.
It's all merit.
I don't give a fuck how
many people are in the game
who's best?
- Right
- For sure.
- I don't even spend a fucking second
on any of those people.
Zero, worry about the consumer.
- Make sure that everyone
who's watching right now
follows us on Facebook
so we can continue to put out good content
- Fuck everybody here
unless they've got you know
elderly enabled like hit them up.
Worry about focusing on 20,30,
$40 ads per piece of content
in the greater Naples area.
You will be stunned what will happen.
- Wanna here another mind blowing thing?
- Fast.
- Yesterday, Alexis, your
last guest, great content.
I was his eighth grade teacher.
- What?!
Fuck you!
- Bro, what is the chances
like I was in queue?
I was like two more to go.
I'm like, wait, I taught that kid.
Crazy.
He's such a good guy like
such a good kid, mind blowing.
And did he struggle?
He talked a lot about struggles,
like he was a great kid,
but he had all these fucking feelings
and it manifested in
some like, crazy shit.
- So I re watched it last night.
I was like, now I'm
trying to recall I mean,
before I got into healthcare,
I taught in public school,
at North Naples Middle School, and like,
I remember him distinctly like I remember
like, he was such, I really
knew like deep down inside,
He's like, really good kid.
Just had to find his path, you know?
So Adam, you've really
I almost have the same haircut as you
like you're literally
blowing my fucking mind.
That is like unbelievable.
- Yeah. I mean,
even just pick two people from Naples
being on the same show.
Like literally I taught him, Crazy.
- Facebook
- Watch us, watch us
- See ya
- Thanks Gary
- Thank you.
- Dustin.
- Yep.
Yeah, I remember Adam
brought it up yesterday
in the private chat and
I hoped you'd be on but
- That is insane.
Everybody, If you haven't figured out,
we're taking it to a new level here.
Please share this right now,
please hit the share button.
If you're watching live
on Twitter, or LinkedIn,
or Facebook,
If not, can you grab the URL?
Get like, let's get more
people in this community.
I think there's so much
good going on here.
It's gonna help people.
Please share.
Dustin, do we?
We don't schedule like this YouTube's
like, how do we end the show
where we already have a
URL for tomorrow's show.
That the Vaynernation here.
The ability to like get more like,
Do we have an RSVP for YouTube?
I know we wanna wait for that on Facebook
'cause it does better if we just go live?
like where are we at with that?
- We can do that,
like I could set up two,
like events at the same time,
like today and then
tomorrow and the next day.
I could just keep doing it.
Like I could set them all up.
But I also--
- I just wanna set up YouTube
because I think you know,
cuz that doesn't affect
it seems like on Facebook
it affects the reach
if you schedule it versus going live.
- Yeah
- why don't you set up tomorrow's YouTube
or have a team right now do that.
And at the end, let
them make a GaryVee URL
so it's easy for everybody to you know,
like T seven two July 2 or
something, you know what I mean?
- Yeah, and then throw it up here?
- Like the last three minutes,
we should just have everybody
like share it in the comments,
people control copy and paste it.
Like save it to promote it for tomorrow
I feel like we're up to
something really good.
And I feel like I wanna
get crazy on momentum.
- Okay.
- all right.
- Cool.
- Please team and let's make this like,
let's create like a shared
squad like hashtag share squad,
like every time you come on at 9,
you go right into sharing right away.
Like this 10,000 collective people
should get the next 10,000.
Like there's something
very real going on here.
Let's move it.
If you share, use hashtag shared squad.
Cameron, what's good?
- What's going on, Gary, how you doing?
- I'm doing well.
It's really nice to see you.
- Nice to meet you, man.
So I'm a little terrified to be honest
because you're one of my heroes.
And I've been looking up
to you for a long time.
- Very sweet, Thank you.
- I'm trying to get
everything together here.
So I've been working in
IT for about 10 years now.
And in the last year or so,
my career changed tremendously
because I've gained a
lot more responsibility.
So my jobs become more stressful.
In that time, about two years ago,
I started a podcast called
"A word to mysteries",
and I was having a ton of fun with it,
but Because my job has
become so stressful,
and also, me and my wife
just had her first child.
- Congratulations
- At 11 months.
Thank you, he's 11 months old,
so our life has changed tremendously.
So I'm, you know, going into
work grinding at my regular job
coming home and you
know, trying to make sure
my wife is okay because
she's been with a baby
this whole time and I
wanna support her and then,
but I also want to do the podcast too,
because people seem to like it.
But it's also one of those deals
where I've been doing
it for two years now.
And it seems like my
listenership has stayed the same.
So --
- Do you enjoy doing it?
- I do.
- Is it a scapegoat, so
look at it as a hobby
instead of the thing that's
gonna change your business life.
You're doing it for you.
It's no different than
you playing video games,
you listening to music, like
people need to blow off steam.
I literally buy and sell
sports cards to blow off steam.
- Okay.
- You know, like, I think you're doing it
to instead of watching a Netflix series,
you're doing it for happiness.
You need it to balance
all the other chaos.
It doesn't have to become
fucking the Joe Rogan show.
It's there for camera and to be happy.
- Okay, I haven't really
looked at it that way
it seems--
- By the way, I'm sorry to interrupt.
That's the whole point
of this fucking show.
This whole game of life is
about fucking perspective,
the way we look at things.
- Yeah, I've looked at.
- All of a sudden, when
you say to your wife,
and she's like, Hey, you
know honey, I need this.
The way some people, the
way you watch this TV show
or listen to that podcast,
it's therapeutic for you.
It's fantastic.
And by the way, I was as happy
when I had nine people watching Why?
me and that little crew
were fucking family.
They brought me as much joy
as I have with millions.
I'm being dead fucking serious.
That's not me being humble,
- I never looked at it that way.
So thank you for that.
The only problem that I run into is that
I think I've kind of looked at it
I've tried to kind of market it
as an escape for other people.
- Good
- And when that happens,
and yeah, I agree.
The only problem is is that
kind of like a lot of people
have been on your show so I get in my head
because I want it to be perfect
because I want the person
that's like drive to work
that morning to be about that.
- Cameron, you're not in charge of that.
- Okay.
- Watch this, Cameron.
I don't know what platform you're watching
but I'm gonna watch comments.
Everybody in the comments right now,
all the platforms, twitch
big shout out to twitch
I love what's going on there.
I need some shared community in there.
How many people here the
first time they saw my content
thought I was a piece of shit, bad guy,
one of those scummy scummy guys.
Kim, how did you first see me?
Was it good or was it like,
oh this guy's probably got some angle.
Tell the truth it's okay
- I'll be honest with you,
I've never seen anybody
do the content that you
were doing at that time
and I was like this guy is next level
because just because you kept it real
and that's what I tried to
do in my day to day lives.
- So ready, I apologize, a
lot of people being very sweet
at me and I appreciate that
but some people yeah, buddy
like, you know, scummy guy Dustin,
big shout out for you to present like,
why I brought that up
is I'm not in control
of how they saw me.
Got it?
There is no project, there's only Cameron.
- Okay.
- Got it?
The more you think about it,
the more likely it won't land.
- Well, it's Yeah,
Honestly, I'm too afraid to post content.
- Yeah, because you're
insecure about the feedback.
- Yeah, I think that's what it is
because I'll sit here and
record and then I'll just stop
cuz I'm like, You know no
one's gonna listen to this
- Cameron, one person listening to it
and liking it is worth it.
- Yeah, you're right.
You're right.
Because I know a lot
of people like to see--
- Big shout out to everybody
with the lover site crew
#LoveatFirstsight.
I love you fuckers thank
you for that, I'm flattered.
Go ahead brother.
So how could I like share
more of this content
to like Instagram because I would like to
I haven't figured out a way
because I see all the other podcasters
and there are a lot of them that I follow
are just kind of having a conversation
and again it kind of gets
into my head where it's like
no one wants to see me
just sitting there reading.
But is that the kind of
stuff I should be posting?
- First of all, brother
you're doing it for yourself.
Bro if you had one superfan you're good
- Okay (laughs)
- Dead serious bro.
- Let me ask you this because I think
honestly, I feel like it's
added more pressure to me
because I was talking to my wife
because we're both freaking
out about being on the show.
So thank you again for putting it on here.
- Glad to have you.
- But I have a Patreon that
I started about a year ago.
Should I just close that down?
Because it almost feels
like that weighs on me more.
- Yes, yes
- But what about the people
because that's had like a
solid seven or so people
support me through this entire
year of being on the Patreon.
What if close it?
I mean, are they gonna,
like hate me? (laughs)
- No, you put them into a zoom group
and you hang out with them
and have a beer or coffee
or a glass of wine once a
week, you just shoot the shit
become a family.
- Okay
- They're gonna love you more.
And you're gonna make some friends,
and you're gonna love them more.
- And it will come full circle
and I'll actually enjoy it
instead of panic when I'm doing it.
Okay, that's what I'll do then.
- Hobbies are amazing.
- What if
for something like this, to
because I enjoy it as a hobby,
and enjoy the feedback.
Did you think that if
I turn the Patreon off
and I just start posting stuff,
it'll all just come together?
- Hold on second
Hey Dustin, looks like Facebook froze.
I see the comments, I don't
know what's going on there.
What's that brother?
- So should I just start posting?
And don't worry about anything.
- Of course.
Nobody's watching you anyway.
- Okay, and is it okay
just to stay where I'm at
just keep doing what I'm doing
because you look at Instagram,
you look at other people
and I'm like, I don't want my
Instagram to look like crap
because I still want this
podcast to look nice,
you know what I mean?
- Yes, but don't don't forget that nice
is in the eye of the beholder.
- Okay.
Okay. Is that how you
did with your podcast?
- Yes, bro, did you see the early episodes
on Liberty TV, looked like
a fucking hostage situation.
(laughs)
- Okay, so just have fun with it
and then it will take
the pressure off of it.
- Take the seven people
that are paying you out,
make a zoom private group
that you meet once a week.
That's what you're giving them.
You're not even charging them.
They're gonna become your friends.
You're gonna be set.
- Okay, can I ask you this?
- Yeah.
- In a couple months,
maybe like in October,
can I follow up with you and tell you,
- Yes.
- How this has changed everything.
- Yes, Yep.
- Okay.
Well, I appreciate it, man.
Thank you so much for
everything you've done.
- Gotcha, bro.
- Thank you.
- Have a great day.
Dustin.
- Yep.
- What's happening on Facebook?
- I think when I sent
the link out it liked
just froze the feed for a sec.
But I just told everyone to
refresh and it should be okay.
- Is that true?
- I mean, I think Yeah,
like I went on my end
like through my personal
account and it seems to be fine.
- Okay, it looks like it.
Basically let me know if we're good.
All right, why did you send the link out
because I thought we were
doing the URL on Youtube
not Facebook?
- In case they want to
convert. (laughs)
- I see you posted the
YouTube link into Facebook
- Yeah, to everywhere
- I see
- Yeah
- So the one RSVP we're gonna have
is gonna be for YouTube?
- Yeah.
- Good, Awesome.
Let's keep it going.
Sneak one more in.
- Cool.
- It's all Gucci.
- Uh Oh, Tea with GaryVee
share squad, share squad
- Share Squad
- To share it on Twitter.
Hi, Gary.
It's a real honor to talk to you.
- What's your name?
- My name is CJ.
- Perfect.
What's it stand for?
- Christian Jiovan.
- Let's go Jiovan, good to see you
What's good?
- It's a real honor to talk to you, Gary.
I've been consuming your
content for at least three years
and I have like some
context and a question.
Just gonna give it all.
So I love being a recording artist.
And if it looks like I'm reading,
I do have like some bullet
points I'm just kind of--
- Half the people read their questions.
So I'm used to it, don't worry.
- Cool.
So yeah, I love being a recording artist
and I do wanna grow so
in the past three years,
I have gained like a small audience
by literally talking
to so many of your fans
and like liking them
first as you would say.
Like, back in the day, I would
have notifications turned on
for a bunch of YouTubers, like mainly You
and I was in digital agency world
so I had a bunch of YouTube accounts
like that I had access to, so every time
a new video came out, I
would rush to my phone,
go to the comment section.
And I'd be like, Guys,
don't worry about who I am.
Here's all my songs to put in the vlogs
if you're a creator reading this
like it wasn't like about me
it was the kind of shady thing
but I felt like I was selling
flowers to the homeowners
like it was weird.
But it kind of worked.
I got hundreds of streams like
in just a couple followers
and it was like a small
like little snowball
and that would result in
some fans listening and--
- While I'm with you, you
know, even though I was five,
I'm not pumped or proud
about the flower thing.
You know, like, doing the right thing
is always the right thing.
You know, I'm not pumped
about the flower thing
or the shack thing, like you
gotta do the right thing.
So keep it in mind.
Keep going.
- Yeah, I totally hear you.
It was my like, quickest, like--
- I get it
- Resistance, and a lot of
people ended up taking the music
and they used it so I feel good about like
providing signups for the videos.
- Yeah, for sure.
- And that will result
in some fans, listeners.
And then you know, I
ended up meeting Jason,
a very good guy, stand
up guy on your team.
And he's put my music
and some of your videos.
- I'm aware
- And I was in New York City,
and I got to tour Vayner.
And it was amazing.
It was a blessing.
So it's kind of like a
testimonial story of, you know,
kind of like went from shady
tactics in the beginning
and then evolved into
like better practices.
- Honestly, it's a lot
of what I'm trying to do
with my content.
The last three, four years especially is
take kids that come from
the same place as I did,
and say like look, if
we're gonna be businessmen,
let's be honorable men.
Let's be kind men,
let's be empathetic men.
Let's be noble men,
let's do the right thing,
period
- 100% 100%.
You know things from there
kind of compound a little bit,
I ended up with a couple
million streams on Spotify
and I want to scale my awareness.
So I've been supporting my passion
with income from operating in the
digital marketing agency space.
So managing clients and
I learned how powerful
paid Facebook and ideas for new discovery.
And I'm actually a
technician like on the ads,
like I know how to run it.
And I also know how powerful
TikTok is for discovery.
So my main question is, I'm
also trying to save money
because I live in an apartment
with my girlfriend's parents still,
but I've been putting
all my money into ads,
and stuff like that, and
you know, best mixing
and just putting into the music.
But my main question is, like,
should I start like leering back on ads
and like, save 1000 a month?
So it's like,--
- Yeah, yeah
Yes, I think balance matters.
I mean, let me rephrase.
The answer is Yes or maybe no.
If you and your girlfriend
and your girlfriend's parents
are all about you being
there for four years,
then I don't mind betting the farm.
- Okay Okay,
- But if you and your
girl are kind of like
getting to go somewhere like then.
Listen, saving money is always right.
- Okay
- Always.
- Okay.
- Period.
Do you know how many
people woke the fuck up
because of COVID on that?
they got their stimulus
check, now that's gone
and we're nowhere close yet.
So now what?
- Yeah
- Saving money and selling
shit around the house
is my number one favorite thing.
You've been in this
situation for four years
at the parents apartment?
- Yeah, and I've been running ads
but I haven't had enough
to even have impactful ads.
So it's kind of like spinning
my wheels a little bit.
- Listen, if you could save 1,000 a month
if you were talking that kind of,
I mean, are you capable
of saving 1000 a month?
- I can.
- That's huge bro.
Do that.
You have any savings?
- I've just spent on my wheels right now.
So like, maybe, two grand.
- You have debt?
- No, uh three grand in student debt
I left in the first semester.
- Understood.
Pay off your debt, because
it's got interest, right?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, get rid of that.
So like, start with that 2,000, 500
You know, like, it's gonna be ugly here
for a couple more months.
You'll sell that Nike hat
(laughs)
you know, put that shit on,
you know poshmark or something.
If you're capable of saving 1,000 a month,
I love you.
I think you could have an incredible year.
Pay off that debt, save the 1,000 a month
that means you can pay off
the debt in three months
based on what I'm hearing.
In three months you're out of
debt, four months without debt
and maybe nine months
because you want to keep
a little bit of money to sit like but
and fucking save bro.
- And then when I have something saved,
now I'm ahead of my expenses.
So in case something
happens, I can just take
what I was gonna dump on ads
and save my life if I needed to
or I can just run ads like in it.
Okay, Okay.
Thank you so much.
And then that answers that question
- We need to make saving money cool again.
- Oh, yeah, I agree.
I need to make discipline
a thing of my life too.
I'm also I've been considering some ways
to monetize as an artist
outside of streaming and merge
and some creative ideas
or maybe like having fans
like invest in my releases
for like a portion of
the streaming royalties.
Get some like
- 100%, yes
- Okay, okay,
- Access, access, creating,
you know, a scenario
where you're, you know, doing
three hours of teaching people
what you've learned for you
know, 50 bucks 100 bucks a month
access.
- Okay
and this is the last thing I'll touch on
because you're so efficient
with your answers.
When it comes to that last
girl who was kind of like
she was a marketer, but
she didn't want to like
market all the sides of
herself because it was a little
maybe it was cheesy or
something like that.
I feel that too.
Because Yeah, just do whatever I want?
- Nerd, shit like, if
you're into Dragonball Z
that should be opposed.
- I am
- Bro, I'm out there
fucking garage saleing
and talking about sports cards.
- Okay, hell yeah
- Right?
- Yeah
- I get that you're in
the fucking music industry
and all this shit but like
the most authentic beats
the coolest every time.
- All right, dude.
100%.
- A stack of Legos versus a stack of cash
is gonna win at the end.
Real shit wins, bro
Be you
- All right.
- All right See you, later.
Dustin, big day on Tea with GaryVee.
If you haven't seen already Vaynernation,
I posted on my Instagram I
haven't posted on my Twitter yet.
But this morning we announced
the acquisition of Empathy Wines.
We've sold the company to
(claps)
thank you Dustin, we sold the company
to Constellation Brands,
the owners of things like
Robert Mondavi and Simeon,
some of the biggest brands
in the world, Corona beer.
Is a major transaction.
I wanna thank my parents,
John and meet my partners.
it's an incredible
quick,
you know, accomplishment.
I'm very humbled.
I think it proves out a
lot of the capabilities
of the Vayner kind of
DNA and the execution,
I want to thank so many of you here
that have supported Empathy.
We need your continued support,
we got some back end to this deal.
So I need to sell more Empathy
with Constellations incredible
vineyards and winemakers
who will be able to make even
a better wine to be frank.
So just an announcement
and I'm very proud.
And so it's a big deal.
A big deal.
So thank you so much for that.
And thank you for everybody who's watching
who gave it support.
Thank you for supporting the show.
We have the URL, if
everybody can grab that URL.
Speaking about wine, huge wine text today.
Get ready for that.
Huge actually, one of the coolest ones
but this URL really matters to me.
Garyvee.com/teawithgv0702
Please save it everybody, can
you please in your own chats
right now put this URL so for other people
they can just control copy it and paste it
and maybe you can paste
it during the day today
and tell everybody why
this is one of the best
hours you spend every morning
means a lot to me.
Share squad, I love you
tomorrow morning we get on
new rule when we get on
immediately share the URL
in one way or another to
be part of the share squad
and leave a copy.
Leave a comment saying you're
part of the share squad.
So anyway, thank you so much
for all the support in Empathy.
It's a big deal, big
transaction sales in my career.
And I'm very grateful.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thanks for sharing and I see all of you.
Love you Shirly Joseph,
Thank you, Juan Garcia,
Sean Thomas. Thank you,
Abel V. Good to see you.
Thank you so much Queen Pranua.
Thank you Melissa Lee.
Scoob, what's good?
Master 23 mine, thank you so much.
PJ always good to see you.
Melissa, Thank you so much.
Ginger, Thank you so much.
Jessica. Oh, thank you so so, so much.
DCC Shelly, I'm looking
forward to tomorrow.
See ya.